[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france 24
cada 6 de febrero se conmemora el día
internacional contra la mutilación
genital femenina una forma de violencia
contra las mujeres en la que se ejerce
control sobre el cuerpo y sobre la
sexualidad la mgf es la extracción del
tejido de cualquier parte de los
genitales femeninos por motivos
principalmente culturales y religiosos
es un procedimiento sin fundamento
médico que deja consecuencias para toda
la vida como la pérdida casi total de la
sensibilidad el trauma psicológico y
constantes dolores e infecciones o en el
peor de los casos la pérdida de la vida
se estima que 200 millones de mujeres
son supervivientes
cuando una niña nace ya es perfecta en
sí misma nadie tiene derecho a mutilar
la que importa que sea una tradición que
siempre se haya hecho así
el fondo de población de naciones unidas
reportó en 2021 416 millones de niñas en
riesgo de sufrir mutilación genital
femenina esta práctica cultural
violatoria de los derechos humanos se
mantiene vigente en 30 países pese a los
esfuerzos por disuadir la y criminalizar
la es una tradición que usualmente se
realiza lejos de la vista del público
sin ningún tipo de medida sanitaria y
que causa dolor intenso y riesgo de
morir de una infección y ahora también
preocupa a las organizaciones de
derechos ya ha aumentado la
medicalización de la práctica una de
cada cuatro niñas y mujeres víctimas es
decir cerca de 52 millones en todo el
mundo fueron mutiladas por miembros del
personal sanitario lo que muestra la
aceptación de las autoridades de la
destrucción de la vulva y de la vagina
femeninas
geográficamente la mayoría de lugares
donde hay prevalencia de la mutilación
genital femenina están en áfrica pero no
están excluidas algunas partes por
ejemplo del continente americano lo que
tienen en común la mayoría de las
poblaciones que dañan los genitales
femeninos es un alto crecimiento
poblacional con al menos el 30 por
ciento de la población femenina
compuesta por niñas menores de 15 años
para conversar de este tema están en
ellas o yahaya de traspaso de que es
cofundadora de la ong s baguer ceiba
generation y también nos acompaña a
estudia lo presidenta de la asociación
humanitaria contra la ablación de la
mujer africana hacia tú también fue
víctima de msf con mucho respeto
bienvenidas a ella soy
y bueno voy a empezar a preguntar muy
rápidamente la pregunta que muchas
personas que no están familiarizados con
esta realidad se hacen porque son
mutiladas las niñas cuál es ese supuesto
argumento cultural es que todavía hoy
prevalece
muchas gracias para estar aquí es un
logro muy grande que es el trabajo el
trabajo que estamos en
bueno lo que voy a decir que no es una
cultura
la mezcla serie femenina los bienes de
una cultura ni una ley del frob
es un acto es una
cosas que estamos
trabajando sobre la comunidad africana
la mayor parte de la africana que son la
mutilación genital femenina cuando nace
una familia donde se hace
la práctica de la mutilación genital
femenina
no que no te puede escapar
es una eso quiere decir que la gente que
no sabe qué es la migración y en esta
familia no confunde la migración y el
itam femenina fue una práctica de
religión una práctica donde vengo es el
segundo país más donde hace la
mutilación genital femenina es el
segundo país el 97%
ayer hablemos de la medicalización de la
mgf que es un fenómeno que está en
aumento y que preocupa muchísimo a
activistas como ustedes
efectivamente muchas veces cuando
hablamos de mutilación genital que me
línea
nos vamos a una aldea un pueblo y no nos
damos cuenta de que hoy día hay sitios
que las personas van piden una cita y
pueden y pueden ser
mutiladas y que sea medicalizada no
quita las consecuencias ni quita que
esté mal evitar el dolor el dolor es
sólo una de las consecuencias de la
mutilación genital femenina
tiene consecuencias a medio y a largo
plazo también
pasando por la menstruación el placer
sexual los problemas no sólo en el parto
sino también para quedarse embarazada
entonces medicalizar lo lo único que
hace es evitar el dolor inmediato que
puede ser
cuando te hayan mutilados sin medicación
o alguna infección inmediata pero todo
el resto continúa y no quita el gran
problema que es una forma de ejercer
control sobre la mujer una una forma más
ustedes están en españa y allá se está
dando un fenómeno como a lo largo de
toda de europa y es el de las niñas que
son mutiladas cuando viven en otros
países y regresan a sus lugares de
origen o al lugar de origen de sus
familias como están combatiendo este
crimen
bueno nosotros por ejemplo desde desde
nuestra organización
lo que hacemos es hacer mucho trabajo de
sensibilización de visibilización y de
formaciones profesionales para estar
alertas para hacer la parte de la
prevención y tener los ojos abiertos a
la posibilidad de que tanto viajes a
países de origen como posibilidad que
nunca se descarta de que pueda hacerse
de forma clandestina dentro de lo que es
la unión europea no
a esa tu que se está haciendo con el
tema del matrimonio infantil porque
ambas organizaciones trabajan no
solamente contra la mutilación genital
femenina sino contra otras formas de
violencia incluida ésta pero está la
mutilación íntimamente ligada a esa tú
con el matrimonio infantil
está ligada a el matrimonio infantil y
está ligada sobre la relación genital
femenina
no quiero decir que en otra lucha es
desde la niña que los completos cinco
años o quince años se lean y tratándolo
mitla ya la primera regla y hace el
matrimonio y le ofrece a esta persona ya
ya se casa
nuestro lucha es de vino de luchar para
que no
pueden seguir la migración genital
femenina para que no se canceló el
matrimonio forzado
y jazz
hablando sobre estas otras metas que se
están fijando ligadas a la mutilación
genital la onu en sus objetivos del
desarrollo sostenible fijo que esta
práctica debería ser erradicada para el
año 2030 sin embargo eso no parece
posible cuando vemos cuántas niñas en
riesgo hay hoy en día cuántos países aún
lo permiten o cuántos a pesar de que han
criminalizado la práctica no le han
podido erradicar especialmente de las
zonas rurales usted qué tiene que decir
es sobre el trabajo para esa meta
a ver los objetivos 2030 son objetivos
ambiciosos que tienen que ir con una
ayuda económica igual de ambiciosa
porque lo que se necesita es recursos y
trabajar con las comunidades acabar con
la mutilación genital femenina es
posible no digo que no yo sino no me
dedicaría a hacer activismo y a
sensibilizar a la gente si no creyese
que puede haber un fin pero para eso se
necesita
sensibilización formación e inversión y
contar con las comunidades que practican
la mutación getafe medial desde el
principio contar con ellos como parte de
la solución no sólo no son el problema
sólo con ellos y trabajando con ellos
podremos acabar con la mutilación que
transferida en 2020 en 2030 o 2040 pero
hay que empezar a hacer eso invertir y
trabajar con las comunidades
y ahí está tu hablemos de ese trabajo y
de esa inversión en las comunidades
usted trabaja con la asociación
humanitaria contra la ablación es de la
mujer africana de la cual es presidenta
en qué consiste el trabajo de ustedes
para la prevención y la erradicación de
la mgf
no te trabajo consiste
a mi carro profundizar la lucha sobre el
corazón de la mutilación genital
femenina donde está el foco el visión
ver una visión otra forma de visión no
sólo de visión europea occidental es que
la visión occidental están ya pre por
maroon preparar lo que cuesta mucho
llegar donde está donde está el foco y
dónde está el foco es donde está la
comida lo rural es donde están los
hombres lo que hice en áfrica sobre todo
donde llega la información no llega en
tablón o de información no llega la
sensibilización o la formación la
educación más básico eso es muy
complicado es muy complicado de acabar
la mutilación genital femenina ese es
nuestro deber
nosotros que estamos luchando sobre la
relación genital femenina
para llegar a donde donde está el
corazón y rojo donde punto rojo es ahí
hacer
la formación sobre yo sobre todo del
baba más bajas de la mutilación genital
femenina que es la mayor en los padres
la madre es a los niños pequeñitos todo
incluido en mimo globo el mismo
formación para que puedan acabar la
migración y finalmente deja ya
desaparecieron rápidamente usted cómo ve
la experiencia en el campo como
activista cómo están cambiando estas
concepciones de que una niña que no está
mutilada no es pura o no puede casarse o
no puede ser madre usted cree que se
está avanzando
si se está avanzando porque cada vez se
está hablando más nosotros por ejemplo
reunimos a grupos tanto hombres como
mujeres para hablar de esta conversación
y preguntarles y decirles por qué no qué
necesidad hay de solo en necesitar tirar
a la mujer para casarse con ella a la
vez intentamos fomentar que la mujer su
único futuro no sea matrimonio porque
como bien dijo mi compañera están
relacionados porque porque hay que
cambiar lo que se entiende como el rol
de la mujer el objetivo de ser mujer
entonces en el momento en que podamos
apartar matrimonio como única salida
para las niñas
podremos acabar no sólo con un
matrimonio forzados sino también por la
mutilación genital femenina
pues mire le agradezco mucho y también a
ustedes por todas las apreciaciones que
nos entregan la verdad es que este es un
tema a veces lejano para los
latinoamericanos a veces difícil de
entender para personas que desde el
privilegio no padecen no padecen este
sufrimiento y estas violaciones de los
derechos humanos así que de corazón
gracias por acercar el tema a nosotros y
les deseo un feliz día y a nuestros
televidentes que sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y nos vemos próximamente en
ellas allí
[Música]